the invasion of ukraine has sent energy
prices soaring with huge implications
for the global economy and household
budgets but has the time come to take
the ultimate sanction and ban russian
oil that was a suggestion from u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken at
the weekend and just look what it did to
the oil price already rising since the
invasion on february the 24th it
exceeded 139
a barrel at one point before falling
back and prices for next day delivery of
natural gas past 600 pence a therm
that's almost double previous records
that have driven up domestic fuel bills
and these price spikes came from just
talking about an energy boycott and
while the west talks russia profits it's
the world's third largest oil producer
behind the us and saudi arabia turning
out around 11 million barrels a day
that's more than 10
of global production but it's the
world's largest exporter it sells more
than anyone else abroad and this is
where it goes germany takes 30 per cent
of its oil from russia france and italy
and the uk more than 10
south korea the us and japan are also
customers all major economies fueled by
russian oil and europe is even more
reliant on russian gas you can see the
countries at the top of this chart in
the east of europe get almost all of
their supplies from russia but germany
and italy take almost half france nearly
a quarter though the uk
imports just four percent so the taps
can't just be turned off the global
economy would have to be weaned off
russian oil with alternative sources
found but that might mean conversations
with suppliers like iran or venezuela
themselves sanctioned which explains why
european leaders are more cautious about
a boycott
if you now would force european
companies to quit doing business with
russia that would have enormous
ramifications
around
europe including ukraine but also around
the world so we have to dramatically
reduce our dependency
on gas and oil from russia that will
take time an oil ban would certainly
hurt the russian economy but every
weapon in this economic war comes at a
price and families and consumers across
europe could pay it